i look back at how kovit 19 impacted
southeast asia this year and left not
just death but also hope in its wake
in mid-july indonesia experienced the
kind of devastation from covet 19 that
india had just a few weeks before the
delta variant tore through the country
making it the epicenter of the pandemic
in asia at the time indonesia had fully
vaccinated less than six percent of its
population as a result one in three
people were testing positive with many
ending up in hospitals
dw went behind the scenes at one such
facility to see firsthand how healthcare
workers struggled to keep the system
from complete collapse
getting into her coved protective gear
takes some time and more than a little
courage
but nurse desanti is just glad to have
equipment available
after graduating from nursing school
last year she was sent to the front line
of the pandemic in jakarta
and became infected herself
a few months after she recovered the
second wave hit the country
[Music]
we even had to rotate the oxygen bottles
for patients in the emergency room
and they kept coming and coming even
after we were out of beds and oxygen
those who came had low oxygen levels i
was overwhelmed
officially kovid has claimed more than
100 000 lives in indonesia with many
health workers among the victims
they've mostly been given the chinese
cinevac vaccine
now medical staff like dr puspita are
getting a booster shot of moderna to
better protect them
i'm really tired
this is just me but when there are a lot
of cases i start talking to myself
this is insane i have to work with covet
19 cases over and over i often feel like
crying but then i realize i'm not alone
my colleagues are also working hard
but by october indonesia had passed the
peak of infections but people were still
dying many alone in their homes it fell
upon volunteers to step in and organize
funerals for these victims of covet 19
if only to give them some peace in death
antonio sayano puts his life on the line
caring for the dead the 53 year old is a
member of a so-called quick burial team
one of the many kovet 19 volunteer
groups in the city of jakarta their
motto
is people of joho district we are
responsive agile and tough
the volunteers help overwhelmed cemetery
officials to deal with the many covet 19
victims in indonesia despite much lower
case numbers in recent weeks their help
in this part of java is still needed
i am suffering from all the heat
and all the sweat
[Music]
the funerals process is entirely in our
hands because the others are afraid
it's not just that some people are
afraid many gravediggers are simply
exhausted and can no longer for instance
collect bodies from people's homes
during the peak of the pandemic
graveyards were open around the clock
in july alone
570 people died here more than in the
previous 12th month
normally hayono works as a cleaner but
in the pandemic people like him have
prevented the entire system from
collapsing his family is proud that he
volunteers
but they also fear he might get infected
the volunteers hope that the fast burial
of bodies will not only bring down the
infection risk enhance the mortality
rate but also help to reduce the
psychological burden for morning
families
hyonu is a christian and says he regards
helping as a duty
yes
we're actually a little afraid
but we throw that fear away and put our
hope in the almighty
it's great to help people in need
and make sure things run smoothly and
safely
and with all the precautions in place
haryana is positive that he can achieve
this goal at the end of the day
with a negative result
in myanmar meanwhile a double crisis
pushed the country to the brink this
summer political instability after the
military coup and a brutal second wave
of covet 19. thousands of healthcare
workers had walked out in protest
against the junta the few hospitals that
stayed open couldn't keep up with the
strain many people turned to religious
groups for oxygen to treat the sick
it's just after dawn in yangon myanmar's
largest city
in front of this mosque the line for
empty oxygen tanks slowly shuffles
forward
people have already been waiting for
hours desperate for a refill of medical
oxygen for loved ones with covid19
if we want to get medical oxygen we have
to come here early even though i came
here at around four in the morning i had
to stand back in the line as some people
had already arrived
for many in myanmar treating kovid 19 is
a do it yourself project
oxygen and hospital beds are scarce
the mosque decided to offer oxygen
as a way to help
initially we thought of distributing
meals to covid quarantine centers like
we did last year
but we changed our decision as we saw
people in desperate need of medical
oxygen
it's available here free of charge
religion ethnic background doesn't
matter
all who wait are served it's a lifeline
as most people here can't afford to pay
prices have more than tripled with the
infection surge
the military government has not been
able to effectively manage the health
crisis
authorities are now even forcing oxygen
factories to close so we're struggling
to get enough supplies to refill the
oxygen tanks
at public hospitals there aren't enough
medical facilities and they're finding
it hard to cope with the demand for
oxygen and other essential drugs and
equipment
with the country in crisis these muslim
volunteers say they want to join with
the buddhist majority in the fight
against covert 19
and many in need are taking up the offer
since they have nowhere else to turn
in malaysia the pain of loss was still
fresh during august the month of the
hungry ghost festival buddhist and
taoist families traditionally take this
time to honor the dead with gifts and
one religious shop owner came up with an
item that many had wished to give
departed loved ones
mr leong makes the jab many departed
loved ones never got
covid19 vaccines
except these doses are made from paper
devout families are buying them up as
gifts to appease the spirits of the dead
the kovid 19 situation in malaysia is
quite serious
many people died before receiving the
vaccine
therefore i hope with this product
it can help the deceased to fulfill
their dying wish
[Music]
the heartache over vaccines is high this
year
thousands in malaysia have died before
getting the chance to get the jab
mr leong can barely keep up with demand
for his paper sets
things
families who bought the paper vaccines
will in the end burn them as offerings
during the hungry ghost festival
when spirits are thought to return to
earth
though this vaccine couldn't prevent the
death of loved ones
many hope the gesture will at least
bring them peace in the afterlife
another place where kovat19 has taken a
heavy toll is the thai capital bangkok
among the many who died were some of the
owners of the city's well-known street
food stalls and as we report some of
their children are stepping up to the
plate to make sure their businesses
continue to thrive
it is now one of the first things out of
which
does when setting up his food stall
alongside the michelin stars he places a
photo of his father who died this year
of covert 19.
he ran the stall for nearly 50 years
turning it into a must visit of the
bangkok street food scene
for adewitch there was no doubt he would
continue serving up the stall's renowned
rolled rice noodles
this shop was what my father loved the
most
and i love him the most
i have to keep it going
no matter what
i'm like before
stalls like this one in bangkok's
chinatown were under threat even before
the coronavirus pandemic facing
competition from upmarket restaurants
and resistance from city planners
wanting to clean up the crowded
pavements
but some say you can't beat these
gastronomic gems
handed down from generation to
generation
this noodle stall has existed for so
long since when my mother and my aunt
were young people know that it is famous
when they come to chinatown they know
that they have to come and eat at the
noodle stall under the old cinema
building
it's why sarisa saitan keeps on going
her mother was another well-known street
food vendor who died of covid
theresa's had to learn quickly how to
make her mother's favorite duck stew
i'll be overjoyed if customers say our
duck still tastes like my mother's
it's given me some encouragement
some tell me not to quit because they
can't find food like this anywhere else
and so in this corner of bangkok street
food is now more than just about its
taste
in the time of covid
it's about keeping memories alive